hello welcome to the final overwatch
hero guide and you know what day it is
oh my it's May Day Eric Tay it's always
May Day May the game baby
yep listen to this overwatch hero guide
if you want to get May of the game let's
get the ball rolling here Eric
endothermic blaster tell me about a gun
it looks like it's kind of a pea shooter
but it's actually pretty decent to get a
head shot right yeah it's pretty strong
the right-click is pretty much she
shoots out an icicle and it can headshot
people I've out sniped some widow-makers
not good way to locate him but you know
you can do that it's really useful after
you freeze someone so the primary attack
with the endothermic blaster is to just
kind of hold it down it'll freeze a
opponent eventually and once you freeze
them that's when it's time to queue up
the right-click for the icicle to the
head and it's like game over it's all it
also slows them down which is something
I take it and realize at the start once
you get that like that freeze beam on
them they just start to slow down a
little bit I'm you know early players
they kind of get freaked out by that
they're not sure what to do they try and
fight you what they really should be
doing is running away especially ones
like tracer and whatnot and you know
certain tanks that don't have a little
bit of range as you can kind of bait
people with that thing as well yeah it's
really powerful um like you said you
want to get away from it because you got
you you underestimate it basically
because once you're frozen you're pretty
much dead unless your tank you know it's
really good against Ganges it's really
good against Lucio's Mercy's really good
against Reinhardt even and he doesn't
you know stop blocking to deal with you
who doesn't see you as well I get a hand
behind to really get in that way another
sort of good combo you can use with
Reinhardt a lot as well and then certain
tanks it's ice wall tell me about ice
wall head of the work ice wall has so
many good uses it's good for just
traversal but as well like you said it's
good for kind of swinging up teams it's
good for kind of blocking damage
incoming damage you can block like
soldier 76 alts you can block McCree all
tiers is hiding oh I better put up the
ice walk around my team
also you can use it to trap opponents
you know split them get a healer on at
their own you know don't let them run
away because you've got the ice wall
behind them also I like to use it like
after I ice block which is another one
of her abilities to just kind of make it
safe for myself yeah let's talk about
ice block so this basically allows you
to you know pop yourself into a little
tiny mini glacier ice cube thing yeah
make heels up and it also protects you
from basically all damage right
yeah you're invulnerable in that state
it's really good again multiple purposes
because you can use the ice block to
even block High Noon if people get
behind you also it's just a great
sustainability kind of thing like I can
do things on my own that the healer
doesn't have to be next to me because
then I can heal myself it's one of the
reasons why I really like playing Mei
she's very self sufficient yeah and so
good at just denying people you said
about like blocking high noon I mean I
saw walls great for doing that as well
words otherwise though don't block your
own team stuff I've had that happen a
lot where I've thrown something up
writers you know McCree was about to
finish somebody off where that would
have fan of the hammer and I mean she's
kind of really good at just distracting
people getting around hassling them kind
of like tracer and Genji but is that
what you should be doing how should you
play Mei Erik that's definitely one of
the key ways to play her um you want to
get to they're healers you want to kind
of annoy the Reinhardt's you want to
freeze those kind of squishier
characters because you can left-click
and then kill them with icicle really
easily it's just a head shot they're
just standing there for free and pretty
much another way to play her too as well
is I've seen her as kind of like a
bodyguard for your own mercy because
nobody wants to come up against a Mei
everyone goes oh my god there's a Mei
yeah you know like I have to be careful
because she's gonna freeze you or she's
just super annoying because she has so
many different diverse tactics I feel
like there's a real flip I feel like
people stay away from me if it's
one-on-one but if you're with somebody
else you can take and make pretty
quickly so do you think that's fair if
you're Mei and you're kind of you've got
two people maybe honing in on you should
you kind of like back out of there yeah
you probably want to back out or you can
try to use your ice wall to split them
and it also depends on you know how low
their health is who you're fighting
against because sometimes you can get
away with it but yeah you definitely
want to take those one-on-ones because
you're probably gonna wind up most of
the time she looks like a cute little
girl but a lot of damage in there as
well you can really sort of once you've
gotten good at may actually cause quite
a lot of damage to the opposition team
so she's good as an offensive here as
well like just getting in there and
causing trouble right yeah definitely
she like I said can take out a lot of
the squishier heroes in the lineup and
she's just a good harass character even
though she's not the fastest but she's
super annoying I'm talking about
irritating people man her oldest super
irritating it basically not only freezes
one person it freezes a bunch of people
if you can land it right yeah it's it's
really strong it's good for you know
capture the points it's also good for
kind of like zoning people out if you
know you're going
win and you're on a payload you're like
okay if I throw the Alta blizzard out
here they're not going to be able to get
to me and it's good for wombo-combo so
like if you call it out it's like okay
I'm gonna freeze guys and it's like okay
here comes the reaper or the FAR's just
like clean up and you do take a little
bit of damage as you're being frozen and
it's like you said it's super annoying
and that's May the 21st hero on our 21
hero guides thank you so much for
watching all of our hero guides make
sure to check out the playlist which
should be linkable at the end of this
video and enjoy playing overwatch